ils sont venus chercher des réponses ses
parents d'élèves veulent connaître le
futur de l'école maternelle marc laurent
on l'a su par les membres de parents
d'élèves fcpe puisque les cartes
scolaires ont été annoncés le 11 avril
si ma mémoire est bonne on souhaite
conserver cette classe qui est plus ou
moins programmé à la disparition et
l'école parce que on a une école de
quartier c'est une âme ses 40 ans
d'histoire aussi dans cette école et on
souhaite conserver cette qualité de
scolarisation en cas de fermeture les
élèves seraient dirigées vers deux
autres établissements de la commune
l'école composé de deux classes connaît
des baisses d'effectifs actuellement
comme beaucoup de collectivités en est
en train de justement de regarder une
réorganisation et n'ont pas demandé par
nous mais demandé par l'inspecteur
d'académie puisqu'aujourd'hui vous le
savez aussi ont des restrictions qui
font que ils essayent d'optimiser par
rapport à remplissage de classe et en
dessous d'un certain seuil bien
évidemment ils réfléchissent à des
fermetures de classe parce que au niveau
des enseignants ça pose problème
plaisir possède 28 écoles pour trente
deux mille habitants de la ville dément
les rumeurs d'une destruction de
l'établissement pour construire des
immeubles l'école marc laurent pourrait
fermer ses portes à la rentrée 2010 est